hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey we are going to
watch today the Godzilla king of
monsters the monsters doesn't matter yes
it does any of these monsters mmm yes I
believe Trump Mothra before we hop into
that I wanted to say a major thanks to
all you beautiful sons of B words who
have been following us over at our
patreon page over there we do weekly q
and A's we also do TV show reaction
watch longs for so many shows that
includes Gotham Riverdale supernatural
attack on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and my hero academia and
John also does music video coverage as
well so major thanks to everyone who's
been following us over there check us
out if you liked it did plett call to
action
hello hi
Oh Oh
[Music]
or or 11 Wow zero damn
yeah volcano make sense
oh my god beautiful yeah let's change
accent whoa a lot of good close-ups on
this John this trailer like Star Trek
there yeah Wow beautiful wide
[Music]
and it looks like Ghidorah is the main
villain in it which will make sense with
like so a history system yeah yeah I
mean you got mothers like queen of the
monsters and you got those like king of
the monsters and the plot seems pretty
clear and straightforward more than
before yeah yeah whereas the first one
had this like hint of tone and style oh
my god I'm gonna be king of shutting
that damn dog off anyway this trailer
had a pretty clear plot of what was
going on because the first one seemed to
kind of hint at sort of
environmentalists issues and stuff like
global warming and whatever on a monarch
side of the story yeah yeah for me good
and it would make sense to with like
Ghidorah kind of the frozen and that ice
thingy at the beginning of it before
Ghidorah is unleashed and everything and
Rodan breaking out of the volcano and
all that so it seems like it'll still
deal with those things but obviously
godzilla is now on the good guy side
yeah with the humans do you know he kind
of always has a confusing agenda
whatever that movie needs is whatever
guns yeah gonna be this side yeah it's
it looks like Ghidorah will be the main
baddie out of them all I know we got
Rodin in here we got Mothra in here but
it's gonna be Godzilla and Ghidorah
they're even teasing that with that epic
shot like this is not gonna shot dude
what the first Godzilla did which was
like juicy goods okay you know that
seems like one of the main theses of
this trailer is sort of we're just gonna
go for it british-owned tins gonna look
amazing every time cuz the main flavors
I got from this was just the frantic
disaster monster movie tone and then
just the beautiful sci-fi of it all with
these gorgeous white shots of the
monsters facing off it really kind of
communicates what they said they wanted
to do have like Mothra be the very
ethereal kind of godlike one have Rodin
be sort of the underdog and then of
course you have King Ghidorah which is
you know one of the hugest God
yeah this looks scary massive I think
and really dread heavy yeah and I'm
wondering how it's authentic to that
will it actually be because this is
Michael Dougherty who's you know the
work outfit or they're like
trick-or-treating Krampus has you know
it's got us like horror scary elements
in there but there's not a like whimsy
and it's fun and you know none of that
Michael's already touch here at all this
is like super serious and they had that
one moment that had a slight sense of
levity whether in the whatever I don't
know the courtroom or yeah oh yeah and
they're all a you want to make Godzilla
or pet yeah yeah and then Ken Watanabe
no it will be his you know like that
that was like the one slight levity
Pavan but everything else seems very
harrowing and very serious and like
people in danger and everything so well
I got it's more of what I think we all
wanted from the first one I think people
were surprised by what we got with the
first one and a lot of people like that
but in terms of what you know trailer it
seems like what they're showing us in
this trailer is what we're gonna get
this looks like a comic book you know
yeah it looks more down the Popey a bat
hole that you wanted like with the
realistic perspective perhaps some of
the time but less of the you know sort
of really good sort of thing and I gotta
imagine that Michael Dougherty's sort of
cheekiness is gonna come out in the
character stuff and the dialogue cuz
these movies are always filled with a
lot of different characters who are like
scientists military guys and kids oh
yeah I mean I get the sense that it's
really Bobby Brown a bear for mega or
the main characters in here oh I'm never
sure Millie Bobby Brown yeah but you've
got like Thomas Middleditch you've got a
wide ensemble like a bigger ensemble
than Pryor and in terms of like the
creature effects I love the different
types of color palettes were getting
here from like the blue to the fiery
that seems like it seems like whatever
like moth or and Godzilla both have blue
which would make sense kind of
complementary of the king of the
monsters queen of the monsters then you
got like Rodin with the fiery image you
know I like how wherever they're from is
what like the the color palette is
matching with it oh yeah it's so
beautiful and I also really like in
terms of the monsters how the way
they're handling with the cinematography
is like some of these shots are
so close-up and in-your-face and very
personal with these monsters we gave
clear images but a lot of times I like
these more silhouette type of imagery
that you get here yeah or they're kind
of blending in with the weather the
environment the shadows I really love
that kind of creature aesthetic as well
yeah it has a very elemental vibe and
the colors and all the visuals and stuff
when you're by the water you know you
it's very blue you know you feel it very
enhanced by that when you're by the
volcanoes yeah it's very apocalyptic
especially the other colors are enhanced
I mean this looks like a painting so
much of this looks like a painting yeah
so I'm very excited for this film this
looks really intense and scary and
emotionally harrowing I'm looking
forward to this all right guys well what
do you guys think of this trailer man
are you excited for this IMAX you have
me so yeah oh yeah all right guys before
we wrap this video up I wanted to give a
page of the day shout out to a man named
Luke Anderson Luke Anderson is a man who
lives all the way in Spokane it's all
the way in Seattle he's 23 years old
private contractor over at FedEx leads a
whole team of people so while Godzilla
might be king of the monsters you are
king of Spokane which is cool isn't it
definitely king of the FedEx managing
over 20 people or something like that
dropping mad packages I know you're
super busy at this time of year buddy
I've seen the movie castaway I know how
intense it can be right now so you keep
hustling and you keep helping out you
got a new house recently good for you
recently when we talked you know we both
wanted over how we meditates so look at
that no not not moans namaste is that
were supposed to say yeah okay that's it
that's what you tell me every morning
when I wake up and every night before I
go to bed you know just like John
namaste doesn't mean go to hell so Luke
thank you buddy
you're the bomb hope to hear from you
again soon
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification but I
always thought that's creepy when you do
that you know it just looks creepy you
got a weird in it I don't know just look
screams don't shoot man it's like it's
such a like a hardcore feminine thing to
do it you got like
long hair and the beard just looks like
creepy to me thanks man thanks for stuff
you guys can take us out on patreon TV
sure we got stuff there see you guys